- All right, so we need another break.
- Okay. Can I do this now?
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- Your staff has been so kind.
- Thank you.
- [Laura] Your staff has been
really, really wonderful.
- I love my staff.
(audience applauding)
- And particularly I
wanna thank your IT guy,
- [Kelly] Tito.
- Tito.
- Yeah!
- Who helped me with my
phone before we came out.
So, is he around?
- Are you giving Tito
a shoutout right now?
- [Laura] I'm giving Tito a shout out.
- Wait, Tito, Laura
Linney just asked for you
to come down here!
Hey, what's up Tito?
(audience cheering)
There he is!
So, Laura wanted to
thank you for making sure
that her internet connection was-
- I just wanted to thank
you very, very much
for all of your help.
I know you came in and
he kept my phone secure
and all of that, make
sure that no one invaded.
- That's for you, Tito.
She's miked.
- That's your mic.
(Kelly chuckling)
- I think I know what's gonna happen next.
- So I just wanna say,
from me and everyone
here, you've been bunted.
(Kelly and audience cheering)
- That is right Tito.
And a special shoutout from Audra,
who, along with everybody here, thanks you
for giving us all peace of
mind while we shop online
when we're supposed to be working.
And Laura Linney just bunted you too.
That's amazing.
- Thank you, Audra.
- [Kelly] It's so amazing!
- Got it? Got it.
- I love that you were like, "ma'am."
(audience laughing)
Tito, she's got a mic on.
(audience cheering)
You are so awesome for doing that.